i'm fascinated with scotland uh my wife
is uh
uh mixed heritage and she has a lot of
scottish blood and uh i think she's the
better for it i am as i've mentioned 100
irish pure
103 irish um but
i'm fascinated by the the the scotch
people
and scotland you've done it you've done
ireland though right i've been to yes
i've been to ireland and i know i want
to know explain scotland to me first of
all if you're any indication you people
swear like crazy you're very you're
artists at swearing
yeah like it's well it's just part of
the language mainly i mean you know we
still get the occasional pearl clutcher
and edinburgh and stuff who gets
offended by swearing but it's absolutely
like i learned swear words from a young
age and
um the only reason they ever had power
was because other people gave them
power like we heard i heard adults
swearing i heard teachers swearing like
they tried to hide it from you they
weren't you know effing and jesse
jeffing in the classroom and stuff but i
remember once when uh i think it was
about eight or nine
i got in trouble because i think i'd
said like [ __ ] in the playground or
something and then
my mom had to come into school and they
told her and i went home and
my mom was like you can't swear and i
said why not and she was like well
um
because and my dad was like you can't
tell him not to do something if you
can't justify it like yes
it has to be a lawyer wait a minute you
had a reasonable father
yeah i did a very reasonable and he
applied logic
to conversations with your mother
yes this is more fascinating than
scotland
well there's so much i need to learn
from you
they're outliers i yeah um and he was
like if you can't explain to him why
he's not allowed to say these things
then then you can't tell them not to say
them that doesn't make sense and i
remember my mum just being like all
right okay well don't do it in school
and don't do it in front of your grand
cause it upsets those people and i don't
want to be in i don't want to be seen as
a bad parent and i was like oh great
well i can i can keep that end of the
bargain well you have a great joke in
your book
about how ubiquitous and common swearing
is uh in scotland and it's about when
you go to buy a uh
a computer uh keyboard in scotland yeah
there's no there's no spacebar it's just
the word [ __ ]
that's because that's a that's that's
the like for when i grew up especially
in fife like that's that's our version
of um
like you go what's his [ __ ] he's
[ __ ] [ __ ] watch his face from
[ __ ] you know from he was on conan
last week the [ __ ] no not the woman
the [ __ ] bloke the one with his
[ __ ] hair
my favorite jokes are visual and and
have this visual truth to them and so
when i read that joke i started laughing
and then i was just picturing someone
trying to write something very erudite
on their computer keyboard in scotland
do you know what i mean which is well
the mail of course moth must reproduce
because and then they hit the [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and then of course everyone scotland
reads it and they don't even notice it
just looks like a space to them yeah
well i mean i've got the the reason
swelling works a lot
better in scotland because our vowels
are short like and that's the key
persuading swelling should never
dominate a sentence it should always
just sort of be like like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
like that's bastard [ __ ] you see how
like that's very
when americans swear because you guys
sing everything because you're you're
happy like when you swear you say [ __ ]
bastard [ __ ] you're like
like that's not how it's meant to be
that's exactly how i say it
you bastard
um wow you got me down